you need to bet on your strengths and
don't give a [ __ ] about what you suck at
if you want this if you want bling bling
if you want to buy the Jets if you want
to do work entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I'm a
humongous believer that ideas are and
that executions the game and so the
reason I think that people are missing
why things succeed is because of
storytelling I love black and white data
I'm obsessed with it
I would never take a note like that
scares the piss out of me what these
three people are doing right now just do
that I'm like nope this thing matters to
me my friends there are a million
reasons why not but there's one great
reason why nothing in life is free
nothing happens overnight he's an
entrepreneur investor author public
speaker and internet personality after
graduating college in 1998 he assumed
control of his father's liquor store
business through e-commerce and email
marketing he grew his father's business
from 3 million to 50 million dollars in
revenue he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here
his top 10 rules for success you need to
bet on your strengths and don't give a
[ __ ] about what you suck at you're gonna
way too many people this room are gonna
spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives trying to check the boxes other
things that they're not as good at and
that you're gonna waste a load of time
and lose I highly recommend auditing
yourself or if you have no empathy or EQ
or self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
chips all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside that is limited phrase
that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one you know like and so that's
it that's what I got so thanks for
having me how do you get money to do
what you love you don't write I lost a
shitload of money when I started doing
what I loved what you do is you position
yourself to succeed so for example if
you're doing something else and you and
you want to do this thing you love you
do it
hours you work 9:00 to 6:00 you get home
you kiss the dog and you go to town
right I mean you start building your
equity in your brand and whatever you're
trying to accomplish after hours you
everybody has time stop watching lost
that's a good overheard right
that was a good overheard so you know
what I mean I mean if you want this if
you want bling-bling if you want to buy
the Jets if you want to do work that's
how you get it to make questions
I'm entrepreneur it's very great but not
all days are great in a company so what
are your tips and tricks for tough days
I think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like it's there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur
not to mention 98% of entrepreneurial
ventures are gonna fail so there's gonna
be a really bad day in your future you
know hopefully not for you um for any of
you you know for me I don't you know I
think this is a very personal question I
think it's how you're wired I'm so
all-in entrepreneur I prefer the pain I
think one of the reasons I love the Jets
so much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I I love the climb to me
the setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it can be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things they can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I could make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most
that it would mean nothing and it
very consistently rewires me very
quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put it in perspective it's money
and you know what up until I had a
daughter even while I was married up
until when I had Nisha four years ago I
secretly wanted to lose all my money I
had this weird twisted dark fantasy of
losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind you mom my
assistants got a great thing now in this
once in every four months somebody sends
an email saying I've got a huge startup
that I want you to invest in but you've
got to sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says [ __ ] you right and and the
reason is I'm a humungous believer that
ideas are shot and that executions the
game right we've all got ideas
everybody's got ideas do any ideas we
all have here we could probably sit here
for the next two hours draw them all out
record them and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years
and so I think the thing that is another
theme in entrepreneurship is there is
way too much fodder brought to the idea
Hoover was magic cab three years earlier
uber is not an idea uber existed it's
called magic cab but the guys that
executed sucked so they lost so I think
you know if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea I'd
like to suffocate it because I think the
actual situation is what you actually do
with it you know the reason I feel
storytelling is the most underrated
skill and business is because it doesn't
get talked about a whole lot and I don't
think that people realize it's happening
and most of all I don't think that many
feel good at it so like when I watch a
Steve Jobs keynote about a new product I
don't care about the new tech I care
about the iPad or the iPhone I could
about the way he was presenting it you
know when when I see David Blaine this
is a magician if you ever pay attention
to what he's doing he's story telling
you the whole way and that is a big kick
so if you understand what the consumer
wants then you backtrack and you tell
the story to get them emotionally there
that's how things sell that's marketing
there's a very big difference between
marketing and sales and so the reason I
think that people are missing why things
succeed is because of storytelling and I
think it's overlooked I think people
look at the X's and O's and the black
and the white but I think storytelling
when done right takes a product that
should have sold 100 million dollars
worth of stuff and it sells a billion
dollars worth of stuff in nineteen in
2001 it snowed in New Jersey
on December 23rd which was one of the
busiest days of the year
typically December 23rd is the busiest
day of the year in a liquor store and a
woman called us we just started shipping
and her case of behringer White
Zinfandel wasn't delivered first of all
I appreciate the people that know what
behringer white sin is good job the
entire case by the way 15 pack the
entire 15 pack case cost $45 we're doing
about forty thousand dollars an hour in
the store she calls I find out about it
somehow it was buzzing cuz I was on the
floor selling I am the premier salesman
on the floor as you can imagine I find
out about it and we're debating what to
do she needs it for her Christmas dinner
I grab the case throw it in my car and
drive to Bergen County to deliver it it
takes me two and a half hours to
complete the whole thing the woman was a
hundred and ninety four years old
we didn't have a lot of lifetime value
on the back end there she looked like
Yoda and the best part was I delivered
it all pumped with myself and she said
great and close the door
awesome everybody especially my dad who
was pissed that I left because all the
customers that came in asking for me or
that I could have sold everybody who's
baffled I can't tell you what the ROI of
driving through the snow in my car to
deliver a case of $45 pink shot to a
woman that looked like Yoda was but I
can tell you this over the next two to
three years that story became the
foundation of how we treated every
single customer it became our
competitive edge and those are the
things that matter to me I love black
and white data I'm obsessed with it the
day when the nerd beat me I understood
that the nerds beat me and I respect the
living out of data conversion funnels
all that but I'm telling you right now
that there are way too many running
businesses today with this and not
enough people running businesses with
this
and again I swear on my life I am not
Mother Teresa and I far from run my
business just on this but I'm telling
you right now the reason I amassed my
following the reason why I continued to
retain it is because my percentage of
this far outweighs everything in this
room I mean it that's how I feel and
that's how I try to roll every day and I
promise you if you are able to figure
out how to afford how to afford the
allocation of this in your business more
your long term value will be
dramatically higher your long term
business success will be dramatically
higher your grandparents your
great-grandparents build businesses
based on this it's how we built the
whole thing we got really lean and mean
when we went to the suburbs and big box
stores and all we cared about was
dollars and it's great and the data
matters and continue to use it and use
this tool and understand it but I'm
asking you one final thing when you go
home if this talk meant anything and by
the way I fundamentally believe only
three of you are gonna act on this talk
I do because what I talk about is
ridiculously hard and massively
frustrating and takes forever you know
like everything that's good in life if
you do anything because of this keynote
there's only one thing I ask you to do
because as any as I got I'm a practical
here's what I want from you when you go
home look yourself in the mirror and
audit everything you and your business
do I promise you that if you audit from
top to bottom of expenses and effort and
time and energy and payroll and all that
if you audit all of it even the best of
us even the InBev's
which is the company that bought
Budweiser they built their whole
business on like printing on both sides
of the paper and all that hoarding even
the most efficient ones of us are doing
20% dumb job if you take that 8% that
13%
that's 16 percent of dumbshit that
you're doing paying that person that's
not bringing any cultural value to your
business having that contract that
you've just been in and you just renew
because your busiest [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] you're doing if you take any piece
of that percentage and you apply it to
giving a [ __ ] about your customer it
will be better for your business going
forward because for the first time since
we all lived in small
towns where your reputation was the
complete backbone of how you did
business for the first time because
technology is bringing us back together
in a small town for the first time being
good and caring and following up matters
if matters how about doing something
random act of kindness for a current
customer not the ones that unsubscribed
or left you know how you always do nice
when they're going how about while
you've got them reallocate your thought
process I'm telling you because the
tools that the is the umbrella of this
organism en't are getting so good so
good you know what that means all that
she's about to become a commodity
emotional e.q is going to dominate
business over the next decade and I
implore you start paying attention and
oh by the way I'll leave you with this
you know what the best part is it feels
good thank you the ability to adjust is
the entire game like I'm so proud that I
changed my mind every day my dad used to
get so pissed when I was building wine
library he would always be like he's
like he would say like three months ago
you said Ricky was gonna be the best
employee I'm like I changed my mind he
fire him or or he's like you said
sparkling wine was important now you
just eliminated it from the key spot I'm
like I changed my mind like my ability
to only be comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest asset as an
entrepreneur like I would never take a
note like that scares the piss out of me
what these three people are doing right
now right and so now yeah now that may
work for them and I'm not like back to
the opening statement like you need to
do you like some plenty of people that
make a lot more money than me and one
bigger take notes the key the key though
the key is way too many people are doing
like here's a good one you know what
really pissed me the baba i'm completely
driven by like happiness and like i'm
crippled by like chaos like you know
vaynermedia which is about 500 people
update your
vaynermedia is like completely dictated
by like I'm a dictator of HR like all I
care about is the atmosphere all I care
about is how people intern all I care
about is like how people roll like I
think I've fired four most talented
smartest people that have worked for me
because if you don't know how to play
with the other boys and girls you're out
because I suffocate under you know
conflict and negativity and like
nobody's better than me so you got to go
so what really pissed me off in tech
world was when Steve Jobs his book came
out when he was dying when it was all
about Steve three or four years ago I
literally watched a lot of my tech
startup friends start being like add to
their staff because jobs was tough
everybody fell into the romance of like
I have this big vision and I'm gonna be
a like Steve Wright and I thought that
was really interesting for me to watch
that half decade of like literally
watching people I know and then watching
them act differently because the status
or the icon of the moment and you see a
lot of that and so like that is probably
the energy I'm trying to bring to this
class today which is you can look at
like how people roll and like it's great
to admire and things of that nature but
it's so damn important to stick to like
your DNA right and like what you're good
at and to recognize that you need to
surround yourself whether it's your
co-founder or whether it's the people
that work for you like all I do is hire
the people that are the opposite of me
that bring the other value that bring me
the ability to remember what the that
meeting was about and go make sure it
happens you know like whatever it may be
right and so I think that's another
thing that I would HIGHLY recognize I
delegate everything that I think is not
the single most important things in the
world and then I micromanage the things
that I think are the most important
things in the world luckily for me hence
why I've been able to build big
companies I don't think most things
matter so I don't think I'm any
different than anybody else I actually
think everybody is a delegator and a
micromanager
I just think that my radar of what's
important is different
yes we need to do something with that
that's the guys that's it right there
I'm looks just like you we're all the
same we all delegate we all micromanage
the difference is I don't think most
things matter and what do I mean by that
as I'm trying to think about somebody
watching us for the first time instead
of alluding to like people that have
watched forever most things no matter
like it like I don't know like just
matter that's what it means like you
know like if I was like I don't know I
don't think lighting matters as much as
d-roc like I just don't think things
matter like I don't think like one
client and it's gonna put us out of it
like I don't think one employee is gonna
kill our atmosphere like like like I I
don't think a lot of things matter I
don't think like like a misspelling in a
deck is something that really matters to
a lot of people in my company it just
doesn't matter to me I just don't think
so guys guys I don't think we're gonna
lose a count because we put the I before
the E and if we do them idiots I don't
think not being I don't think not
wearing shoes in an establishment is you
know the biggest thing in the world
clearly if you've watched led1 some
people do and guess what I do not judge
do not judge everybody's allowed to do
their thing it's just like parenting I
will never speak my parenting I talk
about it but it's very holistic like
this is what I do not what I'm telling
you to do this is me but like so
ultimately I think that I'm both like
everybody in the world I just think that
I deem what's most important at a very
very high level on things that most
people you know what a lot of you were
commenting about my five-minute meetings
most of you because you're part of my
community you think it's great a lot of
comments and YouTube and Facebook of
like oh I like daily because Gary spends
five that's nice
I've one comment I work in a small and I
was whoever said this is gonna see this
and be like holy crap he reads
everything I work I've worked at small
companies where the boss didn't even
know my name you know what I mean like
this is cool
but do you know many people think it's
stupid I have a lot of people in my life
that think that I'm very busy and I have
a lot of things to do and why in the
world Gary it's not scalable it's not
sustainable
yeah you're making that face because
you're so in our cocoon but like boy
just like like you know like they're
like don't do that it's not bad nobody
expects you to do it not at this scale
and you have a great culture and you
have great intent just do that I'm like
nope this thing matters to me
so I'm micromanaging the hello into my
company three to six months in and a lot
of people outsource to an HR person or
the leadership so I do unscalable things
all the time micromanaging if I deem
them the most important pitching new
business I like to micromanage that
because it's important to win business
like money helps me keep doing
everything Roberto asks what do you feel
is a bigger obstacle to success a lack
of time or lack of capital Roberto this
is a tremendous question I think the
biggest obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is the
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negatives
and guess what both of them are
obstacles when I started winelibrary.com
transformation from my business I had
time I've worked my face off every
minute but we didn't have a whole lot of
money in our profit Center so it took
more time right it's just the way it is
today I have more money but boy don't I
have time but neither ever ever will be
an excuse for me and so just a drill
this through the throat of the
vaynernation
that's right I went that graphic don't
smile d-roc here's the bottom line I
refuse to allow you to get an answer to
that question because both of them are
firmly square in the excuse column and I
have no patience for that there will
always be problems let's talk about a
million other things that are a way to
stop success the health and well-being
of your family members so it takes your
mind away from execution the country you
live in government and political you
know concepts at these moments I loss
startups in China that I've invested and
that got traction but then people that
were wired into the government decided
to not allow it to happen and then the
startup disappeared not as easy to be an
entrepreneur there it's still a
communist country
sorry it just is and so all these things
can be problems right there's a
competitor with a billion dollars who's
also skilled and punches you in the
mouth and knocks you out in the first
round right the world changing I mean
there's just a million obstacles right
the media one bad coverage of you a
moment in time you know what I think
about a lot you know what I think about
a lot let's get really real this is why
we did this show I always I'm a human
being and I always think about a moment
in time what if I just say the wrong
thing at the wrong time right what if I
call out China for being a communist
country in an episode while I'm on a
rant and somebody who's watching doesn't
like the way that tastes and it takes
away a business opportunity for me in
China in seven years even though I'm not
trying to zing it's just things that I
saw what if what if you know what if
what if I look down on my phone while
I'm driving even though I've really not
done that and I hit somebody and I kill
them and that becomes the story and
they're like forget about the story
about what you think of me I will never
recover from that because I killed
somebody because I needed to check a
tweet these are moments in time so there
are so many things that can keep you
from being successful right the the
people that you invested in having
something bad happened to them so it
slows you down my friends there are a
million reasons why not
but there's one great reason why which
is you've just got a persevere no matter
what it is it's just the way it is it's
hard being an entrepreneur it's hard
building a business everybody thinks
it's so easy that there's an entitlement
there's a disaster zing in China here
because my us thing right now there is
an insane generation of 18 to 25 year
olds right now that think they're
entitled to having a business because
they saw the social network movie and
everybody's decided if you're a kid and
you know what tech is because you used
Instagram early on you're entitled to
actually build a business building a
business is hard and you know what makes
it really hard
everything that happens every day of
every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the truth is there's a
million reasons 99 percent of businesses
go out of business
for a reason
and that reason is it's hard and so if
you're watching this show I've got a
sense of who you are and you need to
start creating layers and layers and
layers and layers of skin to be able to
get through because the glamour of being
an entrepreneur the goodness you know
you get very confused by my optimism
because it's my optimism I can't help it
it's just how I roll it's probably one
of the variable 1% reasons why I'm
successful but please don't get it
twisted this is hard every day is hard
and if you don't have the stomach to
weather the storm you will not be
successful and by the way let me throw
you real weird curveball and that's okay
people have to look themselves in the
mirror and understand if there are
number two three four or five six seven
in an organization that has differences
of being a number one but maybe that's
where your skill set
sits maybe that's how you make your
fortunes and happiness and all the
things that you're looking for and so
that question got me going a little bit
Steve because it's similar the context
of excuses and I will never make it
excuse everything that's a problem with
me everything I don't achieve everything
that's a problem at vaynermedia and
everything is my fault and I I succumbed
to that and I respect that and I
actually think that's the way it should
be and so um no excuses my friends
nothing in life is free nothing happens
overnight it all takes tons and tons of
work and tons and tons of talent and
tons and tons of serendipity but my
friends luck
serendipity there's a forced culture
within that you know you don't just sit
in your room hoping and then something
lucky happens nobody just knocks on your
houses door and it says congratulations
you've been awarded this luck comes from
being in the right spot
I've been really lucky because I bleed
out of my eyes every day of my life and
work my face off get really lucky when
you have that 11:30 p.m. meeting where
the lucky thing happens pretty cool
since all you were sleeping I was pretty
lucky weird that I scheduled that
meeting because I did a ton of things
for 30 years that allowed me to even
have that meeting in the first place
that gave me the leverage to have that
lucky thing to happen there's no
overnight successes period they don't
exist show me leave a comment YouTube
leave the name explain to me tell me
show me let me know
show me the overnight success because
I'll show you you justifying in your
brain something that is just not period
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because camera and black will
ask this too if you have another
entrepreneur you want us to profile
leave it in the comments below we'd also
love to know which of Gary Vaynerchuk
top ten rules meant the most to you what
you're going to take home from this
video leave in the comments I will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching and continue to believe and
we'll see you soon